(upbeat music)
- All right, seven o'clock, straight up.
You are listening to Redwood Community Radio,
KMUD Garberville, 91.1 FM and HD1,
KMUE Eureka, 88.1 FM and HD1,
KLAI Laytonville, 90.3 FM,
on the web, KMUD.org and in Shelter Cove,
we're at 99.5 on FM translator, K258BQ.
(upbeat music)
- Well, welcome to this month's August 19th,
2022 edition of Ask Your Herb Doctor.
My name's Andrew Murray.
- My name's Sarah Johannesen Murray.
- For those of you who perhaps have never listened
to the shows before, you've just tuned in,
it's a once a month radio show,
third Friday of each month from seven till eight PM.
It is a live show and we do open up the telephone lines
from 7.30 to eight o'clock for listeners to call in
with any questions about the show.
So from 7.30 on, we'll be opening up the lines
and the number to call is 707-923-3911.
Once again, from 7.30 until the end of the show,
eight o'clock, the number to call is 707-923-3911.
Again, for people who perhaps have never listened
to the show or just tuned in, it's a once a month radio show
where we are joined with the expert scientific viewpoint,
not opinion, but scientific viewpoint of Dr. Raymond Peat,
who I think has become pretty worldwide known.
I know people in Europe and Scandinavia have called in
in the past and people from across the states have called in.
We've had people from down under
and we've had people from South America, even, calling in.
So I appreciate all those people that do tune
into the show either live or who listened to it
on the archives and the K-Mud archives are available
for about two months post-production.
So from now until about October,
you can go to kmud.org, go to the audio archives,
select the Friday night talk dropdown
and go to the third Friday of the month
to download the show that's been recorded on that day.
And also incidentally, we have on our website,
westernbotanicalmedicine.com a fairly exhaustive list
from 2007 through to about 2020.
But I still have a good number of shows to put on
that still hasn't been done.
So excuse me for that.
So once again, very pleased to welcome Dr. Peat to the show
who I think has somewhat recovered
from some voice hoarseness due to the wildfires
up in Oregon up there.
So I know he was a little bit croaky earlier on today.
How are you doing Dr. Peat?
- Hi, yeah, it comes and goes.
I probably should clarify what I mean
by scientific viewpoint.
I'm not like Fauci. I don't have the scientific viewpoint
but I think the scientific viewpoint is a critical one
always thinking about the evidence
and what you're really implying.
So it's a matter of criticism and thinking.
- Yeah, well, I know you're always able to back up
what you say with either articles or reference journals
or other information that is bonafide published information.
And very often you'll point to various authors
or publications that support what it is you're describing.
So perhaps I think just initially, as we always do
just in case anybody listening doesn't know you
could you just give you an outline of your academic
and professional background before we start the show?
- Yeah, I studied the humanities first
through a master's degree
and then went back in 1968 to the University of Oregon
for a PhD in biology, basically physiological chemistry
specifically the metabolic changes,
physiological changes that happen in the reproductive system
in aging.
And so that's more or less a chapter of dissertation
that I concentrated on what at that time was still
sometimes called metoplasm
or lipofuscin as a basic cause of aging.
- Okay, so engineers just asked me to ask you
if you could speak up a little.
- I can hear you quite well through my headset
but I'm not too sure the engineer can
or if the levels are fairly low on the desk.
So yeah, if you can, if you're speaking on the phone
if you could just get as close to it as you can.
So Dr. Peat, I think what I wanted to expand
with you is your work and your kind of discourse
on lipofuscin.
I know we've mentioned it in the past
and we definitely mentioned it in relation
to polyunsaturated fatty acids
which definitely have, I think that the awareness
from the public has exploded definitely in the last 18 months
with publications coming out saying that they're not safe
and that they are dangerous and that the whole thinking
of the last three decades was quite erroneous
and has actually resulted in quite a lot of pathology
not just obesity and diabetes and other,
the metabolic disorders but all sorts
of other degenerative conditions.
So can I, can I guess just start by going over some basics
with you for these so-called essential fatty acids.
So if you look online, it seems to imply
that they are only available from the diet, is that correct?
No, some very simple experiments make that really clear
but that amount of clarity in 80 years
has hardly penetrated the beliefs about the fats
because industry has found a motive in claiming
that they are essential where the evidence
is an extremely vague inferential type
but the evidence against it is as clear
as for example, you can grow human cells in culture
like for making specific proteins extracted from them
and if you're growing huge masses of cells in culture
you know exactly what they're being fed
and you can feed them on the diet
excluding, absolutely excluding fatty acids
especially the unsaturated fatty acids.
So you know they're multiplying enormously
on a diet of no environmental unsaturated fats.
So obviously any unsaturated fat that they contain
is something that they have made themselves
so that they can't be essential.
The basic or recognized evidence
that we aren't getting an environmental lunal ache
or arachidonic acid and are becoming deficient
in these so-called essential fats
is to find that we are making something called meat acid
which is an omega minus nine series
of polyunsaturated fats and having a long saturated tail
just the opposite of fish oil.
The minus three has unsaturated groups
within three carbons of the tip
and the type we make ourselves,
the meat acids are the saturated fats extend
down to within only nine carbons at the end
and that makes them relatively resistant
to external contact with oxygen.
- So that's kind of, I think that's pretty important
what you've just mentioned about the erroneous doctrine
of being essential and that they are able to be manufactured
and that will bring out way more questions
about the whole fish oil industry
and pumping the narrative with the anti-inflammatory dogma
or doctrine of the essential fatty acids.
I think, well I just want to quickly ask you,
haven't you said in the past
that the placenta doesn't allow these fats to cross?
Is that?
- Oh yeah, it's a very, very good filtration.
And even when the mother is eating fish and grains
and unsaturated fats, the general recognition
is that at birth, babies almost always demonstrate
making some of the anti-inflammatory natural meat acid
showing that they were assimilating very, very little
of the proof of the environment.
And so they're defining the newborn baby
as almost always essential fatty acid deficient.
The formula companies argue that they need to add
basically fish oil extract to baby formula
to make up for the fact that the newborn brain
shows evidence of deficiency of exactly those fats.
And so they do add it to baby formula
and within a few days of reaching the grocery store,
these fats are degrading and becoming oxidized and toxic.
And then after about a month in the store,
degrade even more so you find less and less
of the oxidized fish oil products.
But the evidence is that what you're doing
is feeding your baby rancid fish oil products
which are toxic in many ways.
- Now, haven't you also said that they've done
plenty of experiments to support the fact
that babies that are fed on these formulas
because of these EPAs and other fatty acids
that are in the formula, they can show
that they have decreased cognition, decreased awareness.
And I think we've mentioned this in the past
to the comparison of the kind of quote unquote fussy baby,
not one that's got griping colic,
but it's fussy and active and awake
and just behaving like a normal baby.
- Yeah, those studies were done over the last seven years,
80 years in rats and dogs and other animals
showing that in proportion to the amount of PUFA
in the diet, their brains are reduced in size
and in learning ability after they're born.
So the deficient animals without the PUFA in their brains
have bigger brains, are higher metabolizers all over
and learn much faster.
The difference in learning in the 70s,
some studies said it was like the average rodent deficient
in PUFA having something like a 140 IQ upper PUFA
and a few percent of brain learning ability.
- Compared to his EPA drugged siblings.
- Yeah, and if you look at the aging brain,
right from birth, all the animals that have been studied,
the amount of PUFA in the brain does steadily increase
from the so-called deficient state at birth,
up until a heavy overload state in old age and dementia,
a steady increase in PUFA concentration
bound interfering with cholesterol synthesis.
But as the PUFA content of tissue increases,
the heat production and metabolic energy
of the whole animal decreases in proportion.
So the baby has extremely high overall oxygen consumption
and metabolic rate supporting that fantastic rate
of learning that is normal for a newborn.
- Well, excellent.
- An interesting side note, can you guys hear me?
- Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
- Okay, an interesting side note is I'm not someone
who suffered from heartburn, but when I was pregnant,
all three times, if I ate any PUFA-rich animal fat,
like a duck fat or a chicken fat or a pork fat,
even just the tiniest little bit,
because I was avoiding that,
because I knew those contained PUFA,
because I wasn't eating any vegetables that contained PUFA,
but that was the only time I would get heartburn
is when I ate those fats,
or even just a little bit of those fats.
It was very easy for me to see why I shouldn't be eating
any kind of PUFA fats when I was pregnant,
because I immediately got heartburn.
- Okay, so I think what we've outlined here,
you're listening to our skier of Dr. Jamie D. Garber,
who 91.1 FM, and from now, or 7.30 rather,
until the end of the show,
you can call him with any questions related
to this month's subject of lipofuscin,
Dr. Raymond Peek joining us live.
- I think what I wanna say right off the bat here is,
first of all, that, gosh, the essential fatty acid myth
has just been, again, destroyed.
And the whole, gosh, and the word collusion
gets banded around so much,
especially during this cold COVID debacle.
But the word collusion in terms of the industries
that are multi-billion dollar industries,
and the fish oil industry is one of those massive
conglomerates worldwide pushing this stuff,
and all the academia pumping out the supporting evidence,
as it were, with the studies showing
the anti-inflammatory effect via psoriasis,
or anti-inflammatory effect via asthma,
of these so-called essential fatty acids,
which are not essential.
And the very fact that,
and I don't have any problem bringing this out,
but at the end of the day, we're divine creatures,
and God made us in his image,
and the baby that is born in the mother's womb,
the feeding mechanism selectively blocks
the transport of these products.
Now, why is that?
I think you got your answer right there.
So, interesting, so let's carry on, Dr. Peat.
The fact that these N minus three and N minus sixes
are not essential, but they are found
in many different foods.
And I know you've always said nuts and seeds are number,
well, the fish oil is kind of number one,
the most reactive or the most rapidly oxidizable PUFA,
but nuts and seeds,
that we shouldn't be eating nuts and seeds
because maybe they're not so bad in their raw state,
if they're sprouted, for example,
but when they make oil from nuts and seeds,
they never would have found that volume of oil
within that nut or that seed to actually use it.
So when they come up with canola oil,
'cause corn does have a pretty high component
of N minus three and six oils,
the liquid oils that we are subjected to
and have been for 30, 40, 50 years,
as a result of this huge industry, both number one,
denying the fact that these essential fatty acids
are essential because they're not,
we can actually live without them
and produce them ourselves spontaneously,
but that the foods that have these are beneficial for us
and we need to buy their products,
especially the liquid oils that have been used
and fish oil that's become a multi-billion dollar market.
- The nuts and seeds that produce the oils
and the snakes and frogs and fish
that use them habitually and without any special problem,
they don't think of themselves as food,
but those oils are appropriate for manufacturing
their own energy stores or to be obtained from their food
because they live at a fairly low temperature,
at room temperature and below, for example.
And animal fats at room temperature tend to solidify
and a snake with solidified fat just doesn't work very well.
The same with the fish.
If you're going to have flexible active tissues,
you need to have fats that are liquid
at body temperature and so these fats
which are appropriate for cold animals,
if you put these fats into a very hot animal,
that's when they're extremely unstable.
High temperature plus the fact that they are designed
to be very sensitive to each so that they're flexible
at room temperature, that means that you shouldn't eat them
if you're going to live at 98 degrees Fahrenheit.
- So what you're saying is that it's okay
for the frogs and the snakes and the fish to eat these,
Omega-6 and Omega-3 oils because they're cold blooded
and they're not going to heat those fats up
to a high temperature and oxidize them.
Where it's weird because we should be around 98,
99 degrees Fahrenheit, we're going to rapidly oxidize those
and turn them into free radicals.
Is that what you're saying, Dr. Peat?
- Exactly, in some studies they decided to see
how efficient as energy sources fish oil was for fish.
Naturally it has to be liquid enough to function
at a cool temperature but they added some animal fat,
more saturated fat, so it wasn't quite so fish oil-like
to salmon diet and then put them through an endurance test
and the salmon that were eating salmon fat
didn't have the endurance that they would have
if you gave them a little more saturated fat.
- Okay, so are you listening to ask of Dr. KMD 91.1 FM
from 730 onwards, so you're welcome invited to call in,
number 707-923-3911.
So Dr. P, I think the focus and the thrust of the show
being on lipofuscin and its danger, its build up,
how it's virtually impossible to detox from it, remove it,
gets bound up in neurons and is very much
a aging causative factor and also one that is,
I think, well implicated in neurodegenerative conditions
and I think we can look at a little later
things like Parkinson's, Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's disease, dementia
and those other neuro vegetative disorders
but given that our diet is so broad
and we have access to so many things
and the health industry wants to point us towards the nuts
and the seeds and the fish and all of these things
that are rich in these N-3 and N-6 oils.
I know you've always supported a saturated diet
and using minimal starches too
but saturated fats as a prime source.
In terms of your diet and the amount of foods
that people do eat, do you think it isn't over
or not just over consumption
but do you think that they should be consumed at all?
I think they should be avoided as far as possible.
Yeah, avoided as far as possible, there you go.
So I think the basis of the lipofuscin,
would you outline your understanding of the process
by which things like metal ions as well as stressors
exert their effect on these N-3 and N-6 oils
in the presence of our body temperature
and how destructive these things are
and then we'll get down the rabbit hole
of decreased age and dementia
and all the other neuro vegetative disorders.
Starting in the 1930s to explain why
food got rancid, the process of breakdown of fats
and how it works inside tissues.
It was studied in various ways including model systems
and people learned to manufacture something
that looked and functioned like lipofuscin
by reacting, for example, copper and vitamin C,
iron and just about any kind of fat
and various biological components
including nucleic acids and proteins.
And you can see that a free radical process
is triggered by the copper or iron and reductant
such as vitamin C that attracts the oily materials,
especially if they're unsaturated
and causes a spreading catalytic oxidative process
that creates some more free radicals.
And so you can identify various things
that are pulled out of tissues depending on
which tissue you start the process in.
If it's a liver and you're under the influence
of estrogen or alcohol, for example,
the liver is going to produce
lots of porphyrin, a chemical used for making heme
in energy metabolism.
And that porphyrin will spontaneously amplify the formation
of the lipofuscin and so some ready made molecules
are great amplifiers of the process.
But that depends on the organ and the physiology
of the organism at the moment it's happening.
But it varies with every organ and momentary conditions
of the organ and the environmental availability
of the various breakdown products.
Tissue injury of any sort releases fragments
of the damaged cell material.
And all of that fragmentary evidence of damage
contributes to the formation of the lipofuscin.
And at first it can be only in the soluble form
that can travel outside of cells
between the cells through the connective tissue,
through the bloodstream, back in the cells
in different parts of the organism.
And some of it forms only as particles in lysosomes
or mitochondria or any particular part of the cell
might be where the majority of it starts.
But it all depends on the situation,
the conditions of that particular tissue.
So even though it's a very comprehensive theory
of sickness, aging, and the degenerative process,
it is so infinitely varied that the ability
to believe that it's happening,
it has taken 80 years to pass
from a fairly vague idea of what aging is
to a recognition that it's a very powerful way
of explaining disease, degeneration, and aging.
- And did you say that lipofuscin can be soluble?
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
Okay, so it's not this insoluble material
that is a complex of iron, protein, and sugar residues.
- Yeah, the smaller particles form soluble
medium-sized molecules.
- So for example, when we, okay, so let me just back up.
When it comes to, 'cause I,
when I was looking at lipofuscin and its main,
the main areas that it's deposited in,
essentially, there's three categories, I think,
nerves, cardiac muscle, I think it may have also mentioned
skeletal muscle, and then skin.
And I always kind of relate lipofuscin
with the aged pigment that you see on the hands
because they're visible with older people, for example.
But you have said also that,
that's kind of a separate question,
I'm kind of digressing a little bit,
that the lipofuscin can actually be present
in somebody in pretty high and dangerous amounts
without actually showing itself on the skin.
But let me just first hold the thought with that.
To say that the lipofuscin itself,
I thought it was always the kind of complex between,
like I said, the kind of iron, or copper, or zinc,
or some cation, and some kind of oxidized protein,
and then sugars, and that it was insoluble
when it got laid down into the nervous tissue, for example.
And because it was complex the way it was,
it was basically resistant to being broken down and removed.
But you're saying that there is some lipofuscin
at some point in time that is quite soluble
and freely moving about.
Is it able to be excreted at that point?
- Oh, sure, yeah, some of it shows up in the urine.
- Right, okay.
So, if that's the case then,
okay, I'm just trying to think about the excretory pathways
and seeing, I was thinking about liver support
and liver stimulants and things
that would increase diuresis and improve kidney's function
and removal of waste and that kind of thing,
but if that's the case, then during the day, for example,
if you're using things like bitters, in England,
we just came back from being over there for a few weeks,
but bitters are very kind of European in English
and people use bitters to stimulate bile
and emulsify fats and improve digestion.
Is there any mileage in supposing
that these kind of bitters or aperitifs
could have a positive effect
in removing soluble lipofuscin
and before it gets converted or laid down
into something that is less soluble and more permanent?
- Oh, I think so.
Accelerating your digestive processes in general.
- Okay.
- Are it gonna help?
- Right, I mean, not just using, for example,
like you always recommend Cascara as a laxative
to decrease the transit time,
but even those agents that would just improve
liver function and digestion and excretion in general.
Yeah, okay, all right, so let me ask you this then.
What's the difference then between
the lipofuscin that's found
both in endothelial plaque as a result of an atheroma
that they say someone's died from
because of the cholesterol that's there,
but we know that that cholesterol
is actually a protective mechanism
under which that initial insult is visible
in the forms of the lipofuscin on the endothelia,
but how about also the lipofuscin that's found
as these dewy bodies, these Lewy bodies,
that is very prevalent, amyloid plaque
that's prevalent in neurodegenerative disorders
like Parkinson's or Alzheimer's.
How have they become insoluble
and basically cause the demise
of that person in a neuro-vegetative way,
rather than just aging?
- How many things go into the composition?
It depends on the type of injury and exposure
and the type of fat and the quantity
that you're exposed to, as well as the natural factors
such as the hormone products.
There is such variation that if it's going to be
extremely fat-loving material,
that means it's gonna stick in your nerve cells primarily.
Huntington's disease is very closely connected
to certain types of proof of derived lipofuscin.
Each type of nerve malfunction associated
with a particular protein, like synuclein.
Each variation of lipofuscin molecule
is going to affect which kind of nerve is affected
in exactly what way.
So you can trace its history and even you can work
on unraveling the history because if you know that
it's a matter of a balance between how fast
you're putting it in and how fast you can remove it.
The process of removal is very slow,
but if you essentially stop the formation
by stopping your excess intake of aluminum, iron, copper
and so on and of unsaturated fats and other irritants,
then you can reduce the formation of it almost to zero,
at which point this light attrition
by way of vitamin E can gradually reduce
the amount in the brain.
- Interesting, so do you think then that fish oil,
for example, would be a far more implicated fatty acid
in the production of these lipofuscin
over flaxseed oil, say, or corn?
- Yeah, the type of molecule is extremely variable.
Some of the early studies with feeding a lot of fish
to pigs and horses and dogs and mink in particular,
they identified something called yellow fat disease
in which the animal's fat became a source
of dangerous inflammation.
- Let me hold you there for a second, Dr. Peat.
- Accumulated in a form that created an intense
degenerative inflammation throughout the fat system.
- Let me hold you there for a second.
We do have a caller.
So once again, you're listening to KMUD Garberville 91.1 FM.
From now until the end of the show at eight,
the number to call is 707-923-3911.
Once again, 707-923-3911.
So let's take this caller.
Caller, you're on the air.
Where are you from?
What's your question?
- Yes, I'm from Garberville, California.
My question is, as the general rule,
I love the organic coconut milk,
and I'm wondering what its benefits are,
and I'm also wondering what you would recommend
as another type of nut milk that are an excellent product.
- Okay, so coconut milk, Dr. Peat, I know you're not
too into nut milks, per se.
What have you got to say about coconut milk?
- I'm not especially wild about it.
Studies in the Philippines have found that
people who cook with it frequently
have a high incidence of breast cancer.
- Ouch.
- So I'm not sure about what the natural contents are.
- Basically, what I'm asking is to drink the coconut milk
without heating it, just using it as a general rule
in a cool basis of putting fruit in it, that sort of thing.
- If it's just the actual water,
if you puncture an unripe coconut and get the water out,
but what they call coconut milk or cream
is a manufactured process where they grind up
some of the solid material and suspend it in the water,
and I don't think it's safe.
- Okay, the other question was the nut milks,
what ones do you recommend?
- I don't think there's such thing, they can make
any emulsion that's white and liquid and call it a milk,
a grain milk or a bean milk or nut milk,
but that doesn't have any nutritional value
in a positive sense.
- Okay, the third question was you were mentioning
the linoleic acid, which is one of the most fabulous ones
you can put in your body, and we do always,
under ETs, under consume these linoleic acids,
what other related acids would you highly recommend
that we do consume?
- The coconut oil in itself has some real adaptogenic
properties by interfering with the PUFA.
- And it's thermogenic, obviously it's saturated
and so it doesn't have any of the side effects
of being able to be converted into a lipofuscin product,
and it's definitely a metabolism stimulator.
Okay, I think the--
- Hi, can I just try to clarify for that caller?
- Yeah.
- If he really only recommends coconut oil,
and not, he does not recommend the omega three
or the omega six or any nut seed oils
or nut milks or seed or bean milks
is what basically I think you were trying to say,
Dr. Peat.
- Yeah, right.
- Okay, all right, so let's move on.
Say it again.
I'm really close to it.
(laughing)
I'll be kissing it in a moment.
All right, that's it, turn me up.
Okay, I caught you saying a little while ago, Dr. Peat,
that other reductants like vitamin C
could drive lipofuscin production
in the presence of those N minus three, N minus sixes.
Did I hear that correct?
- Yeah, too much vitamin C easily activates
any stray atoms you have of aluminum iron,
zinc, mercury, and so on.
- Okay, so how does that relate to orange juice
and consuming large amounts of orange juice?
I mean, obviously, following what you're following,
then that wouldn't be a problem,
but if people are out there drinking lots of orange juice,
but they're still eating certain products
that would contain either of these oils,
wouldn't that vitamin C there be a danger?
- Oh, sure, but there are so many chemicals
other than vitamin C, the oranges, citrus fruit in general,
grape juice, fruits and vegetables very widely
contain bioflavonoids which are basically inside the cell,
they are oxidant, and in the right quantity,
vitamin C is an oxidant inside the cell
in the healthy, non-cancerous cell.
- Yeah, but I mean, you just-
- The function of anti-oxidation of the bioflavonoids
and vitamin C comes when you get the right amount in cells,
which activates oxidative processes,
absorbing potentially stray electrons
that would contribute to the fusco.
- Is there any way that you would say
there would be a sure way to get these pumped
inside the cells then so that you'd have
that ability there and then at the cell level?
- I have to use them in moderation.
- Okay, so I just wanna kind of get my head around the,
'cause I frequently drunk half a gallon of orange juice a day,
I mean, for months and months all through the summertime
for sure, especially when I'm working.
So given that that is a pretty good source of vitamin C,
I'm obviously not consuming any PUFA at the same time
because I kind of live on milk and orange juice
during the summer months especially,
but you say in moderation to have this,
you're talking about having this spread out over time
because I do, sometimes I get into a spake
where I drink in orange juice,
I'll almost drink a half a gallon in one go sometimes.
You're saying just the moderation side of it
during the day would be a safe enough way
to get it into the cells
rather than having any negative effect from it?
- Yeah, you're getting equally large amounts
of the other pro-oxidant bioflavonoids.
- Right, okay.
- And so they are helping to keep the cell oxidizing,
but if you take, say, five grams of vitamin C,
then you get this gigantic surge of reductive energy
that throws cells in just the opposite direction
of turning on the lipophus carcinogenic degenerative process.
- Right, this is why you recommend orange juice
and you're not at all really behind vitamin C as a tablet
'cause you also say that the manufacturing process
for this is very, very spurious.
Yeah, okay.
- So basically what you're saying, Dr. P,
is that if you're getting a half a gallon of orange juice,
you might have quite a lot of vitamin C there,
but it's also balanced by the bioflavonoids,
the naringenin and the quercetin
and the other antioxidants that are in the orange juice,
so it doesn't cause a problem,
the vitamin C is balanced and in the right ratio
with the other nutrients.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So would you condone the use of citrus bioflavonoids
because they've been around for a while now
and I've looked at them in the past
and I've wondered what's a bit.
- In the purified form,
some of those can be reductants, I say why,
and excess of vitamin C can.
- All right, so it's probably more a case
of getting whole plant sources
rather than purified bioflavonoids.
- Yeah, I think one bioflavonoid probably
intensifies and works with the system in the same fruit.
- Interesting, okay.
- So we had a caller that had really bad reception,
so he relayed to me, he wanted me to ask you,
why do you think that cow milk is okay for humans
since we're the only species that drinks
another species milk after being weaned?
- Yeah, that's a very, very Southern Humboldt question,
I think, I don't know if the person came
from Southern Humboldt or not, but Dr. Peat.
- What was the first part of the question?
- The first part of the question was relating to milk
and why is it that we're the only species
that drink another animal's milk?
If it was so good, other animals would be drinking milk
and we're the only ones that do.
I think that was the thrust of the question, wasn't it?
Yeah.
I think it has to do with the size of our brain
and our culture.
We have evolved on a high fruit diet,
high carbohydrate diet, and in that diet,
a very high calcium intake happens to be sort of synergizing
with the other factors in the diet
to optimize brain function.
- Okay, so can I ask you about vitamin E's
protective antioxidant role?
Because I know I've read a few articles
that were talking about vitamin E offsetting,
mitigating some of the effects of these N-minus 3 and 6s
and that formation of lipofuscin.
But some authors seem to suggest that really,
we have to take large amounts of vitamin C
to have a beneficial effect.
But what have you seen from any kind of standpoint
of scientific experiment?
- The definition of vitamin E has changed radically
since the first studies in the 1920s and '30s.
It was originally thought of as a fertility-extending
anti-estrogen chemical, but then as the toxic effects
of unsaturated fats became identified,
vitamin E lost its anti-estrogen clot preventing,
heart preventing mystique and was shifted over
to nothing but an antioxidant in the 1940s.
It lost all of its hormonal benefits
to the public knowledge and became only an antioxidant.
But that has now changed back.
And so it's coming to be recognised again
that it's an anti-inflammatory estrogen-regulating substance.
- What kind of dose would you recommend daily
for someone to use as a supplemental form of vitamin E
just to get this antioxidant effect?
And what is those, 'cause a mix took off rules
have been a kind of advertising campaign for some time
in terms of listing exactly what took off rules
are present and--
- Something like 20 or 30 milligrams.
- 20 to 30, okay, interesting, all right.
- And how many, sorry, Dr. E, 20 to 30 milligrams,
how does that compare to the international units?
- Oh, now it's used instead of international units.
- So what would be the comparison?
Would it be like 100 IU or?
- Yeah, the language has simply changed.
You can talk about the different forms
in terms of milligrams, and it's recognised
that they have their value as vitamin E
regardless of their antioxidant properties.
- Okay, but what would be the 20 to 30 milligrams a day
is what you would say would be a good supplement dose
of vitamin E.
How would that relate if someone has a product
that is in international units?
- Has a what?
- Some of these vitamin E products
are in international units, like they'll say 200 IU or 400 IU.
So how would the 20, what's the equivalent?
- Well, sometimes they're still talking in terms
of the antioxidant value
or the D alpha tocopherol concentration.
For about 20 years, you could only refer
to D alpha tocopherol as vitamin E potency.
- And not the gamma and the delta
and the other mixed tocopherols.
They had to be overlooked, but now that effect is disappearing.
- Okay, so when you state 20 to 30 milligrams,
you're stating 20 to 30 milligrams of a mixed tocopherol.
- Yeah.
- Okay, thank you.
- Okay, I know you said in the past, oh, look out, is there?
- I wanted to give a brief public service announcement here.
Please, a caller was quite upset
that there's a couple of goats in the middle of the road
by the airport.
She said they're in the middle of the road
and it's getting dark and she just wanted anybody,
they belong to anybody, that's where they are.
They're by the airport on Sproul Creek Road,
two black and white goats.
There you go, thank you so much.
- Thank you, all right, very lastly, Dr. P,
I do appreciate you soldiering on through this.
I can tell your voice is giving out,
but just say one last thing about estrogen
and we'll wrap up the show for the evening.
You've always talked about estrogen being inflammatory.
We've had plenty of discussion
about why estrogen is bad for you
and how it's counterpart progesterone
is the anti-inflammatory molecule, especially for women.
But estrogen's inflammatory nature,
in terms of its effect on the N minus three and sixes
and lipophishkin's formation,
it's equivocal, correct?
In terms of the destructive effects of estrogen?
- Yes, so you can treat all of these things
as synergizing either beneficial factors or harmful factors.
The amount of PUFA, the amount of ionising radiation,
the exposure to heavy metals
and each of the components is at least additive
to the others.
And so if you do something to oppose
any one of those, reducing inflammation,
you're going to reduce estrogen exposure,
rate of aging and so on.
Tissue fibrosis and inflammation, degeneration,
aging and cancer, all of these can be alleviated
by simple, natural anti-inflammatory things,
including carbon dioxide, progesterone,
thyroid function and so on.
- Okay, well thank you very much.
Let's hold it there, Dr. Pierre.
I'll give out your information
and thanks so much for joining us.
- Okay, thank you.
- Okay, so Dr. Peat--
- Thank you, Dr. Peat.
- Dr. Peat can be found online at www.raypeat.com
and we can be found online, westernbotanicalmedicine.com.
I think what I wanted to bring out from the show
was that the whole concept of these polyunsaturated fatty
acids from many different sources
of which some are touted as being health beneficial
and good for us, or they call them cholesterol lowering
or blood pressure lowering, many, many cases,
this is completely erroneous and not just that,
but that there is actually something that we can do
to mitigate the absorption and the permanence
of these things.
I wasn't even aware that some of these,
this lipofuscin can be soluble.
I thought it just formed into these complexes
fairly rapidly under the presence of iron,
cations or aluminum or zinc or other cations
with the heat that we have in our body
that they rapidly get converted
into fairly insoluble products, but that's not the case.
So definitely a good cause for those people listening out
there from a herb perspective and it's something
that they've always done in Europe for a long time.
Digestive bidders, hepatic stimulants, laxatives,
all of these things will certainly be beneficial
and actually be a very good mitigating strategy,
especially for people who've just found this information out
and want to start switching their fat sources to saturated.
The people that still think that fish oil is good for you,
having listened to this show, I don't know how you can,
it's not true and it's definitely a lie
and it's an industry fighting to maintain a huge hold
on a multi-billion dollar industry.
So yeah, there's things that can be done
and stimulants, hepatic stimulants and bitters
and aperitifs and all of these things
that will improve your liver function
and clearance of waste as well as your bowel function
and preventing constipation will definitely have a bearing
on you not absorbing these things by the same degree
and so therefore it can only be beneficial.
Anyway, so until the third Friday of next month,
hopefully Dr. Peat's voice is better
and the wildfires have calmed down.
I'm not too sure how that works
because they do tend to burn on for the whole summer
but without being negative on that.
I wish all of you a very good summer
and until the third Friday of next month,
my name is Andrew Murray.
- My name's Sarah Johansson Murray.
Thank you very much for listening and joining the show.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)
- Okay, just one more time.
We wanna remind folks that there are two goats
right near the airport on Sproul Creek Road,
black and white and they're in the middle of the road.
So if those are your goats, that's where they are.
Check 'em out.
Make sure your goats are where they're supposed to be.
(upbeat music)